the last 48 hours have been some of the
most overtly anti-semitic in the
American Media space than I can remember
in a very long time a little bit later
we're going to get to one of the most
insane anti-semitic rants I've seen
Short of actual Nazis and it came from
Kanye West that's after but first we
have to talk about failed former
president Donald Trump
seemingly cracking in an authoritarian
fascistic tirade against Jews not only
attacking American Jews but warning
American Jews you'd better appreciate
what I've done for you or things could
get very bad a typical anti-semitic
fascistic tirade which I'm going to
explain to you Donald Trump went on his
platform truth Central known to some as
truth social and Donald Trump said The
Following over the weekend and I do
quote no president has done more for
Israel than I have somewhat surprisingly
however our wonderful evangelicals are
far more appreciative of this than the
people of the Jewish faith especially
those living in the U.S those living in
Israel though are a different story
highest approval rating in the world by
the way not true
could easily be prime minister U.S Jews
have to get their act together and
appreciate what they have in Israel and
here's the warning before it is too late
this is truly disgusting disgusting now
first before we get into explaining the
layers of anti-Semitism here just a sort
of reality
the Evangelical love for Israel and thus
support for Republican presidents on
that issue
has nothing to do with Judaism
and it has nothing to do with Jews the
Evangelical love for Israel relates
primarily to their biblical belief that
if they support Israel it will
accelerate the second coming of Jesus
Christ and implicit in that depending on
which version of Christianity you
believe or follow there is a Rapture
apocalypse the Jews eventually do die in
some versions of the story all the Jews
other than 144 000 of them die
it's Bonkers and so you should judge the
Evangelical support for Israel
as an example of complete and utter
religious Insanity it has nothing to do
with what Jews Like Me actually care
about or are concerned with that's
number one okay now what Donald Trump
says here
is sadly a classic from the anti-semitic
tropes of History why aren't Jews more
grateful to me for something I did for
them that is a classic classic
anti-semitic Trope when Jews don't
accept the leader's cult or the cult's
leader whichever way you want to say it
they are seen as implicitly undermining
the leader and they are bad and maybe
they even need to be punished for that
then there's also the horribly
anti-semitic idea of the good Jews
versus the bad ones out in the diaspora
when we talk about the Jewish diaspora
we mean Jews around the world and I know
a lot of this stuff is new to some in
our audience and and maybe unfamiliar
but that's why we're talking about it
this is a classic this is a classic here
are the good Jews right the ones either
staying within their schedules or
ghettos or whatever and then sometimes
if it's right-wingers the good Jews in
Israel and then the bad Jews of the
diaspora those bad liberal Jews in the
United States and the UK and France and
okay on and on and on and then of course
there's also the threat there
that's the other part of it get your act
together because you know people have
come after Jews in the past
things have gotten pretty bad for Jews
historically in the past you'd better
get your act together and appreciate
Trump before it is too late and bad
things start to happen if you don't
appreciate me
now once you get beyond the
anti-Semitism you also realize that
Trump as well as many others have
absolutely no understanding of the
reality of Jews in the United States as
a community with interests and
priorities that are very different than
those of Jews living in Israel for
example and this goes back to the Dual
loyalty anti-semitic Trope there's this
idea that okay listen if you uh if your
parents or grandparents came to the U.S
from Italy
or from Germany or from Portugal there
is not this thing that follows you
around about
you might still have loyalty to Portugal
if it came down to it do you choose the
U.S or do you choose Portugal or
whatever the case may be and with Jews
even Jews who have never been to Israel
there is this idea of dual loyalty well
I don't know here's what's good for the
U.S and here's maybe what's good for
Israel and these American Jews can't
really be trusted because they they have
a loyalty to Israel that might override
most Jews have never even been to Israel
don't even follow the the politics of
Israel internal or foreign policy
understand that anti-Semitism while
proclaiming that you love Israel is a
standard of the Evangelical right
and it's definitely a standard of Maga
so a disgusting comment from Trump but
nothing compared to Kanye West
plastic is everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year but you can help make a
change our sponsor hold on makes trash
and kitchen bags that are heavy duty
plant-based non-toxic and 100 home
compostable which means they break down
in weeks rather than decades they don't
fill up our landfills they don't pollute
our oceans they're zip seal kitchen bags
come in sandwich or gallon bag sizes to
fit your needs and the best part about
hold on bags is they work I use them at
home they're just as good as all of the
name brand bags you fill them up they
stretch and they don't break everybody
uses trash bags and freezer bags if you
care about the planet you can do
something by using hold on bags instead
and it's a really easy way to do your
part to shop plant-based bags and
replace single-use Plastics all over
your home go to hold on bags.com and
you'll save twenty percent with the code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below